again with the ball in his hands in the  paint floater  short got it back ties it with three  gonzaga has time to do something sucks  for the win  oh  [Applause]  that  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  that'll be remembered that's the biggest  kiss of your car  oh my god wow  with a great finish thinking they're  back maybe in overtime  and look at the poise of this kid we  talked about his defense but how  about that he's sort of the highest  ranked  player in zags history recruit  and that's the reason he came for this  moment to play with mark few  the chance to win a championship and wow  impressive well  jim i love in front of us all these kids  actually caressing and applauding one  another  and that is just some way to end the  classic basketball game  from minnesota wow